we're here in the occupied West Bank
town of Alberta where Palestinian
protesters are clashing with Israeli
soldiers who are responding with live
ammunition as well as tear gas and
rubber coated steel bullets
what they want is to live freely with
political rights economic rights and
human rights that they say the Israeli
occupation has deprived them up for too
long some of it before
that's what they call the two chocolates
so every time there are me telling the
media we're not using cloud we're using
to talk and it's basically live I'm
about smaller caliber it's like 0.32
amuse it should mostly the lower part
but there's also lots of people who got
to shot like the chest with it and scan
can't label some people died also
president Palestinians that we spoke to
here are saying that they are fed up
with the military occupation that
dictates every single aspect of their
life they say that this is an expression
of that anger this occupation that has
been in place since 1967 and the plate
is uprising right now is just another
episode
no one know it and innovation especially
given guanidinium visa day
a couple bucks